there is mixed reaction this morning to
Amazon's decision to cancel a
multi-billion dollar plan for second
headquarters right here in New York City
the company abruptly announced its
pulling out after growing opposition
from some lawmakers union leaders and
activists David Beck knows in the Long
Island City neighborhood of Queens where
the headquarters would have been based
David good morning intense reactions and
feelings on both sides on this one
you're right about that Gail good
morning so that's Manhattan behind me
and right across the East River here in
Long Island City right there at the edge
of the water is where Amazon was gonna
put their new headquarters not just
another facility but a headquarters
look a majority of the polls showed that
most New Yorkers supported Amazon coming
but there were politicians and activists
who opposed it loudly and at the end of
the day they won Amazon walked away from
the deal there wasn't a shred of
dialogue out of nowhere they just took
their ball went home New York City's
mayor bill de blasio says a senior
Amazon executive broke the news to him
over the phone on Thursday the company
would not reconsider its decision to
ditch plans for a roughly two and a half
billion dollar New York City
headquarters all we asked was that they
be a good neighbor and be part of
community and clearly they weren't ready
to do that demonstrators who for months
raised concerns about the project
celebrated near the site where Amazon
plan to build supporters applauded the
deals 25-thousand expected jobs
workforce training and nearly 30 billion
dollars in estimated revenue over 25
years critics however worried about the
rising housing costs and Amazon's
opposition to labor groups and over
three billion dollars in tax breaks
congresswoman Alexandria Castillo Cortez
represents the district that borders the
proposed site we could hire out more
teachers we can fix our subways we can
Acacio Cortez and other political
leaders including president Trump have
criticized Amazon for not paying enough
in taxes this year the company will
reportedly pay zero dollars in federal
taxes on more than eleven billion
dollars in profits in a statement Amazon
blamed politicians
who will not work with us to build the
type of relationships that are required
to go forward with the project some
local business owners like Frank Raphael
say the company offered to work with the
community they were coming to meeting
they were speaking and they really were
trying to do the right thing Frank was
the only person here yesterday who
actually was for the plan everybody else
was against it who gathered to celebrate
Amazon says they're not reopening the
search to find another location they
were gonna open another headquarters in
Virginia they will continue with that
and another facility in Nashville listen
John if you believe the polls that a
majority of people wanted this what
happened yesterday was an example of a
minority group a small group with a loud
voice taking on a trillion dollar giant
and winning that's right David it's a
David and Goliath story thanks so much
David